mais on vient de parler de des femmes on
vient de parler de dieu mais tintin et
vous avez dit qu'il est né dans un zoo
madère catholique
il ne parle jamais d'une vache jamais à
la messe mais non c'est vrai ça pourquoi
je n'en sais rien je ne sais pas je
crois que ça ralentir l action ah bon
c'est pas bon ça va avoir des aventures
vraiment extraordinaire dans une église
dans une abbaye ça me paraît difficile
seulement j'ai vu la présence de dieu
dans vingt deux volumes c'est tintin au
congo il y avait vers la fin il ya un
horrible méchant qui est qui et bouffer
par les crocodiles et châtiment juste
châtiment et tintin sur la berge dit
dieu ait son âme
on s'aperçoit qu'il a une chrétienne
mais c'est quand même un peu bizarre que
ces personnages qui est née vraiment qui
a été suscitée au par les prêtres qui
vous l'ont demandée et qu'il n'ait
jamais je trouvais faisant de la parfois
demandé donc intervenir la divinité
c'est vrai lui et jamais je ne les fais
peut-être cette fois là mais une seule
fois peut-être parce que je ne sais trop
facile tintin étant dans une situation
difficile
mon dieu s'il vous plaît faites que je
sois sauver il est sauvé c'est un peu
facile
le jour où le sauver en oiseleurs je
suis revenu à ce moment c'est moi qui
suis dieu il n'y a pas de mission si
malheureux rendu au congo il ya un
missionnaire où il y avait un faux
missionnaire oui c'est côté rétro que
ses filles et ses fils
il ya eu des missionnaires au congo
jusqu'à très récemment je fais ce que
moi vous tous les matches on est tous à
la porte
l'unité et puis alors les femmes aussi
bon évidemment comines à 15 16 ans non
moi je trouve que c'est un univers où ça
n'a pas sa place je trouve c'est
vraiment ce que vous faites c'est l'anti
michelet parce que non seulement bon
teint s'intéresse pas aux femmes on peut
le comprendre parce que c'est dans les
autres pour aimer ma femme il n'y a pas
de femmes donc s'il y en a il y en a
mais sont des caricatures l orquesta
fiore
il ya une concierge par ci une dame qui
est qui téléphonent qui ici téléphone me
longtemps mais c'est tout oui je n'ai
pas de caricature et les femmes ça me je
n'aime pas si c'est une jolie femme et
que je la caricature c'est plus de
jolies femmes
alors ça devienne castafiore et vous
c'est sage non je n'ai pas de je ne suis
pas à l'aise pour pour faire des dessins
de femmes caricature le prochain tintin
c'est quand il faut deux ans de travail
oui bien merci alors d'autres livres si
vous voulez en savoir davantage sur sur
rgb vous pouvez lire tintin et moi
entretien beke rejet par uma sadoul aux
éditions casterman et d'ailleurs je
soutiens que tous vos albums sont
publiés aux éditions casterman alors
plainte un journal publié un numéro
spécial pour votre 50e anniversaire une
saison de dessinateurs vous rendent
hommage en hommage à tintin par exemple
il ya le montre hélas le maurice qui a
fait l'auteur de lucky luke l'iran là on
voit lucky luke faire sauter tintin et
milou dans un dans une couverture avec
les dalton à côté et puis je trouve que
les cahiers la bande dessinée publiée un
spécial hergé et puis de vous l'histoire
de l'automobile des origines à 10,900
pas de 1900 aujourd'hui des origines is
one de 8 les origines alsaciennes les
laisse absolument superbe dans êtes un
spécialiste de l'automobile n'ont pas
spécialiste non mais enfin je
intéressé à ça la vérité avec les
collaborateurs ne l'ont fait c'est cet
album on a fait des albums aussi sur les
chemins de fer sur les bateaux toujours
sous cette forme là aussi chez septimus
édition